now you spent some time
um pleading this case in front of a
judge there was
no benefit to that like what happened
there
so we're talking from March 2018 to July
2021 we're talking almost you know three
and a half years there
was several adjournments that the mother
tried to get because I think she
realized it was a really hot case
uh so she gets two adjournments because
she said she doesn't have a lawyer and
then we were supposed to have trial in
April 2020 but you know all the courts
got shut down in March of 2020. so we
were delayed until July 21st
so um to answer your question uh what
was the result from that Court well
if I go back to one of your videos where
you talk about uh mothers in control and
how they use children to take control of
the situation I knew before we separated
based on conversations with her like
after she announces the serious
relationship she threatened I was never
going to see my children again she
threatened to take them away she
threatened to leave the province she
threatened to move to Pei she even
threatened to move them to Ukraine and
so I knew she even offered that if I
would sign away the children in that
spot she said she'd never bothered me
for money for the rest of my life well
first of all I knew that wasn't true and
second of all I knew that this is a
person that wasn't willing to negotiate
and so the court system was the only
outlet that I had in order to take any
control over either the situation or my
children because there was no way to
you know negotiate or compromise with
her she was wanted me out of the
children's life you're in your notes it
says that you had a police enforcement
order
um because she was non-compliant and
giving you access to the children yeah
so uh we separated on March 8 2018 on
March 12th four days later we appeared
before uh a judge who actually ended up
being the trial judge and during that
appearance we created a parenting order
that basically gave me the children
every weekend except for one weekend a
month
during the first 12 months after
separation I saw my daughter one weekend
during the first 12 months after
separation I saw my son
the first six months after separation
and then the second second six months I
didn't see him
okay so sorry so let me just recap here
so
she was physically abusive to you
beating you yeah you have a court order
that is supposed to let you have the
kids every weekend except for one
weekend but you only saw them once in an
entire year from what I understand
yes
how does she end up with custody of the
kids like like who is this [ __ ] of a
judge that allowed this to happen
well do you want his name
let's hear it
uh judge Gregory right out
r-i-d-e-o-i-o-u-t and on what basis did
he allow her to have the kids after all
this evidence
the main issue during the trial was the
issue of relocation
so uh what he was trying to determine
for the most part was that should the
children be allowed to relocate to Pei
or would it be required to stay here in
Vancouver they didn't even deal with the
fact that that she didn't give you
access to the kids
he thought here's the funny part so I
actually had a judge in January of 2019
provide me with police enforcement okay
now this is so serious if if any of you
fathers out there have been in a
situation where a mother is withholding
your children you know there's almost
nothing you can do explain that so what
is police enforcement yeah a police
enforcement means the police are
actually allowed to go in and it says in
the court order it's uh so I went to a
judge the judge was Furious and judge
came back a Woman by the way and said uh
you now have police enforcement and
every time she withholds the children
you're subject to a 500 fine payable to
the father
uh you know spoiler alert the trial
judge says oh don't worry about it you
won't have to pay any fines you know
even though you withheld them for a year
okay but anyway when you had the police
enforcement did you did you call the
police when she didn't Grant you access
to pick up the kids I did it twice and
so the police enforcement literally
allows the the police to go into the
mother's home or or any physical
location they think the children may be
and retrieve the parents
after 12 months of not seeing the
children so between the time I got the
court order and the time I used it there
was six weeks
during that six weeks I was
communicating with the mother's lawyer
the mother with the school principal the
school the children's teachers and with
the West Coast Family Center the West
Coast Family Center was appointed by the
social workers to help manage the mother
you know help her transition to a shared
custody situation and so after six weeks
my lawyer just said look you know
there's no point in getting it if you
don't use it it's time to use it and so
on lit on March 8th of Tuesday sorry you
let it happen six times before you
started to use it yeah six weeks that
went on I didn't see my kids didn't see
my kids so what happened like you would
show up you know pick up time let's say
It's Five O'Clock you go there she
wouldn't answer the door or she was at
home or like what happened I'm supposed
to pick up the children at school by the
way that court order also forbid her
from being on school grounds during the
transition okay okay
so I would go to school like six times
and then what happened when you went
well the kids would basically uh walk
right by me walk all the way down of the
bus stop which was at the end of the
school property where the mother be
waiting for them my mother would take
the children by the hand cross the road
and then take them home which is
basically ignore me so why didn't they
come with you
oh because at this point they weren't
coming at all by this point I hadn't
seen my children and my daughter in 12
months my son and six months how old
were they
uh this is 2019 so eight and five
so they're eight and five they walk out
of the school they sue they obviously
recognize you because you're their
father of course say you know come on
kiddo's the top in the car and you know
yeah go home yeah and then they just
ignore you and keep walking yeah they
just keep walking even though we have a
social worker that's communicating like
trying to talk with the mother like hey
we had this very serious court order we
need to start moving you need to be
there encouraging you need to tell them
they need to have your backpacks packed
nope so why didn't you call the cops at
that time to have them enforce the order
the I did after six weeks but I was
trying to after six times after six
times yeah okay so I mean in hindsight
would you be that nice
like would you let it slide that much I
mean you let her get away with hitting
you you let her get away with a lot
actually
yeah
I was hoping I would I thought the
system would hold her accountable and as
it turns out it didn't at all so so
there's a lesson for you guys is that
the system doesn't hold women
accountable to standards you know
especially when it comes to family law
you can't you can't let stuff slide it's
like you cannot even give them an inch
it's like if you have an order to have
the kids at four o'clock and you pick
them at school then you make sure you
get the kids if the kids don't get in
the car with you then you call the
police and you enforce it like you have
to use every means available to you
because just about everything in family
law like I talked about in my book like
the like the deck is stacked up against
you you cannot give them any wiggle room
whatsoever and any being the nice guy
does not work you have to be a tough guy
anyway we can't put you back in a time
to fix that but anyway so yeah yeah so
after six weeks you finally start to use
a police enforcement do the kids like
are the kids happy to see you when the
police get you know them it was
miserable that my uh when my when the
police first of all when I called the
police they said they weren't going to
enforce it okay so I got the family law
system failing me social workers the the
agency everything's like they first
refused to it and I said excuse me the
judge has already made this decision for
you you don't have a choice in the
situation I need you to speak with your
supervisor and I get a call 20 minutes
later sorry 20 or 30 minutes later from
the same Constable saying Mr Morris okay
you know I spoke with a supervisor we're
going to be enforcing your court order
and I said I will be there to pick them
up because I didn't want my children to
be escorted to my home in the back of a
cruiser
so uh the first time I did it the cops
go in the house and there's a fight my
son is fighting with the RCMP the
mother-in-law is is fainting the Mother
wasn't even home when when the cops
showed up she was off somewhere you know
apparently working so it's it's one
thing to take the kids because she wants
us to spend time with it
yeah it's not even with him she doesn't
want me to have the children right yeah
so
so the cops show up and they the cops
obviously call the mother mother comes
rushing home there's a big fight an
altercation and kids are Furious my my
daughter is crying she is uh 19 she's
eight years old this time my son is like
nine
and sorry I'm messing up on the math
there
and my son is is furious he's so upset
at me he's he's uh as I started when the
police finally bring him out and get him
to the car he takes off police officers
are running in the dark after my son
takes off like he runs away runs away
it's about the most miserable situation
you can think of broken yeah like that
would suck as a father of the guy
I mean this is just [ __ ]
um
so the kid runs off doesn't want to be
with his father you're doing everything
you can to be with your kids what did
she what does she do to the kids to get
them to that point where they like I
mean like okay for example uh you have a
picture here on your GoFundMe let me
just put it up on the screen because
this does not look like kids that don't
like their father
right you know this is the boy and this
is his daughter I'm assuming right
yes that's my daughter how long ago was
this picture taken I was taken in July
2022.
okay so my son's already 14 that picture
so I mean like how much work did you
have to do to get to the point where he
would go on vacation with you and stand
beside his father at least like the kids
are like Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde when they
were with their mother they felt like
they had to act in a way that would make
them happy and this is what the
counselors described to me as the
divided loyalty trap The Divided loyalty
trap and this is not something that I
said this is something that the the
child Educators told me that the
children were caught in it's basically
when the children attach or align their
interests with the caretaker for fear of
their own Survival and so if you think
about that for a second it basically
means that when you when you have a very
conflictive mother who refuses to
co-parent and burns the children with
making decisions about their own
parenting time with their father it
basically you know puts the burden on
the children to refuse their father in
an attempt to make the mother happy and
then it forces the father me into a
situation where either I go away
right to relieve the situation to help
my children and then indirectly the
mother wins because now the father's out
of the picture or if I continue to be
part of their life and insist on being
their father no matter what then I'm
creating all this conflict and somehow
it's all my fault but when the children
are with me alone they were totally fine
like you know talking doing stuff but
it's like this massive act they had to
put on when the police showed up they
blanked me they thought it was my fault
did um the child services do an
assessment on what the mother was doing
to the kids
uh right after separation they did an
assessment they didn't interview with
the children
um would you like to hear because that's
pretty juicy too yeah sure um they
interviewed their two children put them
in separate rooms explain the concept of
lying the children told them that I was
uh hitting the mother every day children
told them that I was hitting with
children every day and then they told
them they didn't want to be with their
father after the social workers
explained to them a little more about
lying and press them for the truth they
admitted that their mother had coached
them to say these things it admitted
that the father had never hit the mother
father never hit the children and that
sometimes the mother hits the children
that was the results and that's a public
in the report 500 pages by the way did
that get in front of a judge at some
point
yeah yeah like judge had that and the
judge still let her get her away with
going to Pei with her boyfriend and the
kids yeah well you want to hear the
ridiculous part is Judge Bridal actually
said that he finds no great he dismissed
my allegations of Parental alienation in
his final assessment now I get the fact
that he's not an expert but you know and
I have audio clips and everything and
still
um
it's Indescribable I I yeah so
sorry so that was the results of the
interview by the way the social worker
file was in the mother's name because
they had and I I'm paraphrasing here
they had serious concerns over the
mother's parenting style and and they
were uh uh and about her aggression
towards the father of the children so
it was uh it was really messed up
hey guys I really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out